This is an incredible AI technique where in
goes a photo, and then, out comes a video of
it. But wait, not any kind of video, even
better, a seamlessly looping video. I love
it. What I found really surprising is that
it works quite well on a variety of cases,
not only on simple periodic movements for flowers,
but for even a sleeping cat, and more. Wow.
But, hold on to your flowers,
I mean papers Fellow Scholars,
because look. Boing. And a bigger one. And when
I tug here, a smaller one. These boings work
on other scenes too. And all this little world
model from one simple image AI. Incredible. So,
not just animating the image, but we can
even play with it! How is this even possible?
This is an AI model that has looked at videos and
motion trajectories that happen in these videos,
and based on that, it tries
to create something that they
call a neural stochastic motion texture.
These motion textures describe how pixels
should move when they are tugged
at. How the boing should happen.
But wait a second, if it has this kind of
representation of the motion, maybe it can also
manipulate already existing videos too, right?
Oh yes, look! We can take an existing video,
and even magnify the amount of motion that
is happening there. And I am very impressed,
I just kept looking and looking, and
couldn’t find a single issue with these
videos. It would be very difficult to tell
that they aren’t real. And it gets better,
it can even do a slow motion version of
already existing videos too! So good!
Previous techniques were not nearly as good as
this one in creating these animations. Look. This
image is trying to perform the impossible, which
is, showcase motion in one still image. So what
is happening here? Well, we take a small slice of
this photo and try to visualize how this slice is
moving over time. A previous technique did this,
stochastic I2V is from just 2 years ago, and the
new technique. Okay, this looks better, but we
are experienced Fellow Scholars here. We wish
to see how it relates to the real motion. So…oh
my goodness, look at that. No wonder these videos
are so realistic, the synthesized motions are in
some cases, nearly indistinguishable from reality!
Now, not even this technique is perfect. Look.
If I pull this away, I now have distorted the
original image a bit too much, and what is behind
here? We do not know. Information is missing. Now,
image inpainting techniques already exist,
so that can be remedied very easily. However,
the next one cannot, or at least, not easily.
Look. And the background also does not work here.
Now, I think this will surprise you.
Being a computer graphics researcher,
I have to note that there was an excellent
graphics paper, called Video Textures,
which was a handcrafted technique that could do
something like this…yes you are seeing correctly,
more than 20 years ago. Goodness! Then, the input
was a video and it tried to find connection points
where it could be connected back to the start of
the video and playing it again. Thus creating a
looping video from a non looping one. It was a
little more elaborate than that, but this was
the key idea. And it is a powerful idea. I wrote
my Bachelor thesis and a paper 15 years ago based
on this technique, which was a procedural brush
stroke generation technique that could learn your
brushstrokes and apply it to already existing
works. It was a ton of fun and was made for a
feature-length movie. The paper and video of it
is available in the video description. And now, an
animation from a single photo. Creamy, slow-motion
movement even! Love it. And just imagine what we
will be capable of just one more paper down
the line. My goodness. What a time to be
alive! This was Two Minute Papers with Dr. Károly
Zsolnai-Fehér. Subscribe if you wish to see more.